many people don't know that mental
health issues are often misdiagnosed can
you talk about that i don't know if i'd
call it misdiagnosed because you might
actually be depressed so that might be
the correct diagnosis treating with
medication they come with a whole host
of side effects they're very difficult
to get off of once you're on them which
isn't something you're told by doctors
because doctors sometimes aren't
actually aware of how hard it is to get
off of these medications my belief is
that a lot of these disorders stem from
inflammation in the body and
inflammation can stem from high carb or
processed foods that you're consuming
that your body's like not happy with and
that can cause some mental health issues
so there are things you can do i would
definitely look at lifestyle first
what's your diet like are you eating a
lot of grains a lot of carbs a lot of
processed foods lower that try and eat
whole foods eat more meat meat is not
the culprit here see if that improves
your mental health look at how much
you're exercising look at how much
you're sleeping look at your
relationships